i want to play a clip for you today from
c-span
now c-span is not a place
where you necessarily expect
the most sort of unhinged political
discussions c-span generally does a good
job of moderating relatively sober and
respectful discussion even when kind of
kooky people call in they tend to do a
pretty good job with it well during the
show washington journal on c-span
recently there was a caller from
tennessee and that caller called in
upset
that there were minorities on his tv
screen giving opinions and he said he
doesn't like it he wants to go back to
the way things kind of used to be and
for those who are only listening to this
clip there's an asian guy and a black
woman who are on the panel on washington
journal and the guy is nicholas wu from
politico
the woman is ebony mcmorris from the
american urban radio network and uh take
a look at this and then we'll discuss it
this is really something comment for
them please when i was a little boy
listen i'm 83 years old when i was a
little boy
i think that by the way i think the
caller is a man although although maybe
not i don't know
okay we're going to stop it there let's
go to nancy apologies i'm sorry and i
and i didn't even start it at the
beginning let's go to the beginning i
apologize current things here in america
that's going on particularly
in the press
and uh the politics of america
i want to know
if uh
we could cut out some of this
if we could cut out some of these uh
these liberal things that are going on
in america just like in on the tv now
we have two minorities and i'm not
giving you minorities
i'm 83 years old caller this that's that
shouldn't be a factor in the vic that we
invite to our program which we did
invite so what's your question or
comment for them please when i was a
little boy listen i'm 83 years old when
i was a little boy the colored people
here okay we're going to stop it there
let's go to nancy apologies for that
uh the colored people are bothering this
83 year old man or woman now i know many
people will react to this by saying this
is an 83 year old these are not common
views well the issue here is that uh
these are actually relatively these are
more common views than we would like to
admit but a lot of younger people
realize you can't say that out loud
you're not supposed to out loud say
i'm really bothered by all these
non-white people i'm seeing in movies
and on television and they even
sometimes just call it woke i mean woke
for some people has become a
a paraphrase in a sense for
i'm seeing a lot of liberals with
different identities uh participating
and being allowed to give opinions and i
don't like that now ebony mcmorris who
was
the the black woman on the panel
she tweeted after the fact quote i was
trying to hold it in but i promise you i
felt all my ancestors rushed through my
body
nicholas wu was right pedro was a master
at intercepting that next time the
response may be different
and this is really you know the person
says i don't i don't have a problem with
minorities so what they're kind of
saying is i'm not a racist i just don't
want minorities on my tv screen giving
me political opinions i don't want too
many minorities in my government or in
my neighborhood or in the same waiting
rooms as me type of moment and what
really makes me kind of sad it bums me
out
the looks on the faces of the guests
there's a bit of a i've dealt with this
before sort of look and that is
that that's that's sad it really is and
so when we talk about well when they say
that they're conservative
what do they want to conserve or what
what do they want to go back to because
for many of them they believe we've
already gone too far they want
conserving means actually let's go back
we often say vaguely well they want to
go back to sort of the 50s right where
yes there were minorities around but
they were much more
it was much more okay to openly say
these are second-tier people they're not
like us yes women were around but they
were much more uh stringently
subservient to men they're talking about
the 50s and if this is an 83 year old
caller
1955 they would have been about 16 years
old
that is exactly what they are kind of
thinking back to and this is different
this is
what is also fascinating is because of
the trump era
we're really used to the neo-reactionary
cartoonish conservative jfk junior's
still alive and
queuing on and this type of stuff
this is much more the 1950s conservative
that we would see a lot more like in the
bush era when they would talk about the
moral majority and getting back to god
and christianity and all these different
things that's this caller this is not
really it doesn't sound to me a trump is
rio neo reactionary it's more of of that
and it's quite saddened it's still
around 83 years old but it's still
around send me your thoughts you can
find me on twitter at dpakman we'll take
a quick break and be right back
one of our sponsors is the daily upside
a free business and finance newsletter
providing actionable insights to make
you a more well-rounded investor the
daily upside is one of my go-to's just
for keeping up with finance it really is
a must read and the daily upside was
founded by a team of journalists and
scholars every weekday daily upside
delivers interesting and engaging
stories to give you context on the most
important financial news of the day it's
a five minute read it's great it's witty
it's insightful it's really worth five
minutes every morning for me plus once a
week they publish a deep dive newsletter
unpacking a more complex business trend
or giving you some domain expertise and
an easy to understand voice as someone
who has to stay up on current events to
produce my show
i really can't recommend the daily
upside enough and there's a reason why
300 000 people subscribe to the daily
upside and start their mornings with it
go subscribe right now for free at
davidpakman.com
upside the link is underneath the video